okay well we heard from a viewer who
really wanted your help in the first
date department so let's take a look at
this clip
hi drew my name is rachel i live in
linwood washington and i'm 46 years old
i have a son that's 17 and this fall
he'll be heading off to college i've
been divorced for about 10 years and i'm
very interested in prioritizing dating i
have recently lost over 120 pounds and i
am very excited to meet new people my
hope is that demona can help me with
advice on how to take on my next first
date first dates are first impressions
and it always counts i could really use
some advice could you help me
please welcome someone i totally relate
to rachel hi rachel hi
um okay rachel what scares you the most
about a first date
well i would say what worries me most or
possibly scares me is if a man hasn't
been completely honest on his profile
and of course the guy that's too
aggressive
demona
what are your general tips for those
particular anxieties or first dates in
general
well i i do want to acknowledge those
things are definite red flags so you got
to look out for those
those uh things that make you feel
uncomfortable that's always your first
guiding
first thing to guide you through the
date i want you to also prepare for the
dates a little bit and to remember how
important body language is so don't be
afraid you got this new body you lost
120 pounds it's amazing amazing
you look so beautiful bacon yeah
so
so live in your body use it use your
body language and then you've got to
prepare for the date so i want you i'm
going to give you a little homework i
want you to create a curiosity list the
next time that you have a date things
that you're just curious to know about
them and also prepare for the questions
you will inevitably get
which are what do you like to do for fun
uh what are you looking for
why are you divorced which you are not
obligated to answer so have a koi fun
comment at the ready when you get that
question because you inevitably will and
then what do you think the ideal length
of a
first date is well actually that is one
of my questions how long should a first
date last
about an hour and i want you to think of
it like this you want the energy to feel
like it is ending on a high point it's
ending in the middle so most people will
remember the beginning of a date and the
end of a date but if the end of the date
is like we went for three hours we had
dinner we ran out of things to talk
about that's what you'll remember and
that's what he'll remember so even if
you're having a great time i know it's
very hard we have to just hold back a
little bit and end the date feeling like
it's in the middle and you'll probably
get an invitation for the next one
rachel
i think you have another question last
question for demona i'd love for you to
ask oh yes i do now if there is no
chemistry and the guy is quite a
gentleman should i go on a second date
oh yeah why not why why not i mean if on
the first date most people are not
really themselves anyway if you're still
curious by the end of the first date to
know more about him go on the second
date if you're still curious by the end
of the second date go on a third i have
a three-day rule if by the end of the
third date you're not feeling anything
then you can let it go but you've you've
given it your best shot i'll give you
like to remember this i'll give you a
little little phrase drew loves my
little zingers
sparks in three or let it be
[Laughter]
that'll keep you motivated
[Applause]
rachel how does this feel great i really
appreciate your vibes very much it's my
pleasure i'm here to help
[Music]
you